hep hep come on help left come on
hip-hip come on Deez Nuts
come on God yep coming Gotti here go
hip-hip Gotti hip-hip come on heck yeah
full of energy yeah full of vim and
vigor whoa jeez ah dude it always goes
back it dicks dicks dicks
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to spore with my good buddy
Wade and a good buddy Tyler who you may
not know but he actually joined me for
the Uno's charity livestream back in
October no odd November of 2012 I think
was December December oh man it was way
way back when we go we've known each
other forever so I'm gonna let him take
the reins we're gonna play it through
we're going to make a lot of really
fantastic amazing creatures that are not
dicks no reiterate they're not Nick's
creatures made in the spore creature
creator very explicit so pick a world
that you would like to start with mmm by
the way he never saw us play spore so he
literally has no idea how to play the
game we're gonna guide him through this
y'all right there you tell me just yeah
upset they're just really tasks Oh new
linear thank you new clinic linear' okay
nuke linear' cool but you're part of
this asteroid that has a Spore of life
transcends all obstacles to see this
planet with life see it I was really
trying to draw out times of the MA
go go go go skip skip skip skip you need
to eat meat so go out there and eat that
meat boy not vegetables not vegetables
are bad for you kids out there don't eat
your vegetables you will not grow up big
and strong unless you're a meat-eater
like us you don't get any pudding unless
you eat your meat you can't eat your
broccoli until you eat your meat yeah
I've said this again you won't get your
dessert of Brussels sprouts unless
you're me yeah yeah oh that thing looks
like it should be eaten interesting you
can't get it get it get it get it get it
get it get it faster get it get it
better get it get it stronger
but it's but yeah oh come on boy oh boy
oh boy guard by the way came here we can
switch that one alright find that one
yeah eat it
yeah good black I did it you murdered
you sweet sweet oh my gosh oh golly
finger me he's on me eat the one shop
for those things they look like thinking
okay or bite them yeah bite that one
again bite it again it doesn't like you
put bite it you need to not bite it on
don't fight it about while running pull
over
well okay anybody buddy what are you
doing get the booty oh yeah oh yeah what
are you driving or we could leave that
Oh what why are you avoiding all the
favor get your bait on joy no you're not
know anything but you are avoiding the
meats let's play there we go oh my
goodness okay finally sees yeah pour me
more me more me or Mel boy more man Oh
dicks dicks dicks dicks dicks at the
heart button hit the arm trying to
escape hit the heart button in the
bottom using some board to escape while
hitting heart button in the bottom hit
the heart button in the bottom hit the
heart button in the bottom hit there but
it's hard but it's a hard button oh my
god but here the button hit the button
there you go go to the hearts go to
lunch girl hearts go to hearts whoa re
over there there we go see there you go
welcome back everyone
fast-forward through the bull oh this
guy now knowing how to play the game so
now we can actually play the game that
you all want to see alright that great
great friends friends alright so now you
get to make the creature of your wildest
imagination dicks dicks dicks dicks yeah
I got a haircut oh it looks pretty
yeah you did good I saw what you were
typing there top no yes yeah there we go
rig
Reagle is your regalis elasaur gala
sauce or a gala sword yeah regular
dinosaur Oh welcome back everybody
[ __ ] of what happened just now trying to
get done we got a great regalis or here
for you so let's see what this bad boy
can do Tyler taking it away that was the
idea ha ha ha ha yeah I'm taking it away
oh god the thing is huge yes not it gets
that a lot
yeah those are herbivores those are
dirty dirty vegetable eaters not
something that I wanted right away the
one without a run away don't run into
coral corner Wow like I got those look
out oh no you know the rules it's yes
and not no oh eat him - Shelly or not or
leave him alone run away what are you
doing keep those yes yes final yeah yeah
it's miss eat its meat eat is me look at
the kids in life you have their kill you
have to kill but you have to kill what's
smaller than you and then it's me Andy
it's me always you to me we're gonna
read up over that look at the kids in
life you know they could stay in school
and eat your vegetables than you and
they listen to your parents and follow
the rules welcome back to the again to
spore with Tyler and Wade after the
[ __ ] of what you just saw sorry
cluster fun plus what you just saw so
now this is a nice bulbs those are nice
balls now you have more of a budget you
have 20 and you have new parts now you
get to make the creature of your wildest
imagination welcome back we didn't
change anything so here we go play take
it away Tyler oh my we got faster we did
get smidgen faster I don't know how much
how are they regalis or 2.0 we're just
so doofy we put wings on our back and
that's gonna make us go super fast ok
don't worry about that kill another
thing that's electric shock II I just
told you dude dude dude dude
now do not die don't be that man don't
don't stop don't no no no no okay you're
fine
blubber but why wait no you're right you
put your butt - you're putting your butt
- its weapons why are you so bad is this
what it's like to be a youtube commenter
ah you die oh you be so terrible he went
for the spa I mean you did aim right for
the spikes after giving me you're trying
to kill your guy that's your mate I'm
stuck in his bubbles well no you're not
not his bubbles kill those green things
yeah okay I begged on him you can do
that - kill him kill him kill him kill
him kill him kill him yeah is this
really what it's like to watch
competence why it was right there
welcome back to the [ __ ]
after the cluster fun that you saw
previously we're here again to make a
cool new creature
for you to enjoy I'm enjoying this
whoa free shape might be changing some
oh oh boom don't but everybody looks
smell the same well it looks so
different are you done and it's still
the regalis welcome back there's more we
didn't change damn thing so just you
know you know the lingo kill things like
with that level there what's that thing
Oh should I roars and oh yeah you killed
that baby right as it was coming out of
an egg no Larry so proud of real room
now you've got Hill the less-fortunate
meet them exactly good job oh my god
what's happening I can't believe it I'll
come back anyway oh yeah are you gonna
bring
all right now brains oh not much we've
changed oh oh we got fins and and
flagellum and flagellum and the lowest
thing we only died once we didn't need
to die at all thank you very pleased now
we're gonna make it land don't do
anything yet
don't do anything it don't turn back
laughing thank you everybody so much for
watching hope this was as much a cluster
fun for you as it was for us thanks
Tyler and wait for joining us we're
gonna roll right onto the next stage and
hope you enjoy it too thanks again and
as always we will see you in the next
video bye bye adios you don't get a song
I don't think you know